welcome to episode 2 of podly the
official peacemaker companion podcast
brought to you by hbo max and dc we got
butterflies we've got vigilante and
we've also got white dragon
i don't know but we have an amazing
interview with chikuriuji who plays mern
so stick around and let's get into this
why is there a bald eagle in your car
that's equal eagerly is your pet eagle
yeah is your dog named doggy
all right do you have a daughter named
daughtery
hey y'all i'm iffy waddyway and i'm
fiona nova and welcome to pavli the
official peacemaker companion podcast
from hbo max in dc and we got a dope
show for you but as a reminder since
this is you know episode 2 and you might
not get it yet this is the companion
podcast each episode is going to talk
about everything that happened in the
episode that is referenced and before
that so if you haven't watched episode 2
yet hit the pause go back watching come
meet us after it's not a pre-show this
is a post show so we'll see you after
the show look we got a dope episode
ahead of us so let's just jump right
into it
[Music]
this was a super fun episode right yeah
this was maybe well i was very excited
to see it because episode one kind of
set it set it all up oh yes so now we're
kind of we're trying to get some answers
so what what are we what are we dealing
with okay first of all what the [ __ ] are
the butterflies we don't know yeah and
so we just know their code name it's a
code name we don't know what's going on
with them we don't know if these are
these are robots if they won't or
if they were manufactured yeah man your
fact we don't know what's going on i
just love that it was project
butterflies i think it's a good tie-in
with suicide squad because it was
project starfish yeah yeah i really did
like that and now we're on to project
butterfly yeah so now you're like okay
what is this gonna be what's this next
thing gonna be yeah peacemaker pulled
out this like rune covered
wi-fi router yeah and it's just
and we don't know what it is but then he
has to get out he was outside he could
have ran away but he had to go inside
because he had to get his clothes
yeah he couldn't find his socks yeah
yeah which is devastating well also
that's what was fun is like hearing like
john cena curse because like someone
who's like been following john cena
since he was the rap and wrestler uh
he's always had this like squeaky clean
goody goody persona like he's what you
know in in wrestling you call a baby
face you're a a a good guy that you sell
to the kids so he's never done anything
raunchy for most of his career and now
we see this new science saw the new side
of here which is he does really well oh
he's like
kind of nailing it yeah he's nails
comedic timing is out off the charts
it's so
funny
uh but yeah now we're seeing these like
two cops yeah they're like detectives um
they're coming after him we're
introduced to them really because
they're gonna yeah they're gonna be i
feel like they're gonna be important
he's escaping he's trying to figure out
and then he enters into this random
apartment and essentially
holds hostage these two just random
people and
the woman starts to fall in love with
him
that whole interaction was just so what
is happening you know when you just have
you know
a partner who's not assertive and you
got someone who comes in and they're
wrapping you up with rope but they're
still checking in on it right because
that's the important part
you can use the ropes but make sure
you're checking you're checking in
making sure are you good yeah are you
good are you still good let me know you
know exactly so that was that was
interesting that was an interesting
thing uh to add but i think that also
just adds to peacemaker's charm and yeah
you kind of understand where he's coming
from well but it was very interesting
too because
you know
i was you're wondering like how the heck
is he gonna get out of this they're
right they're gonna go and then next
thing you know
everything leads back to peacemaker's
dad uh looks like economos uh did what
was good
um is the hero we needed i know everyone
was upset and the show everyone was just
upset why did you do his dad yeah like
me i i was okay with how that transpired
that's exactly
who i
there was nothing in my heart that said
that was a wrong thing that happened and
even if it was being framed yeah
you know he must have done something
else yeah it was just about time yeah
yeah so i think yeah we get the dad now
is going to jail
and we finally meet
the character the one and only the
vigilante
so how did you get out anyway i thought
you were in prison for life it's a
secret dude i'm your best friend are you
not
well who's your best friend then someone
you met in prison i knew it
dude
it's eagley obviously another show would
have them just be heroes because you
know most heroes are saving the day and
it doesn't matter the collateral or what
the what the battle the effects of who
they're getting or how small the crime
is super villains superheroes they are
all not one-dimensional beings they all
have goods they all have bads but i
think vigilante i don't know that whole
interaction about his dick
poor peacemaker crying in his bed and he
just does he just was like please i know
i know your dick is out i know you're
digging up just turn around and look
he's like no i don't have it i promise
you what a great friend yeah he's like i
promise you guys just gotta turn around
and look i'm gonna force you to look
yeah so that you know yeah but yeah so
we see uh we see peacemaker and uh yeah
and they um
they they had that appliance shootout
they did they had like fun it looks very
fun i also liked that you can kind of
see their relationship because in the
beginning it felt like at least to me it
felt like vigilante was maybe like this
fanboy yeah of some oh yeah but it's
like oh no
they know each other and they've been
friends for a while
you know he said his sidekick was
eagerly it seemed like his psychics
might be vigilant but it also just seems
like vigilante just follows him
everywhere and and peacemakers kind of
just like okay yeah you can join me or
just like not really like helping and
it's just like yeah you can come come
through yeah i know which i like that
relationship yeah
and you know at this point we've tapped
in and we're really kind of seeing the
cohesion of peacemaker's place in the dc
universe and it's funny because you know
you know the arrowverse has a vigilance
right this one might be my favorite
version this is your version
i think it might be i think i really do
like i really do like how he was
portrayed and just how it is
i'm i think he's gonna probably be one
of my top favorite characters for sure
you know who's not going to be my
toughest no we know he's dead
yeah because he was in jail he's in jail
and then like all the white supremacists
are kneeling to him and i was it was so
funny because i really resonated with
that guy who was in that chair he's like
i died for this yeah
and also i like the
it's real funny of like seeing the white
supremacists uh get on their knees and
call them the white dragon which
i'm not i i have thoughts but i'm not
i'm not just let
uh as we watch but
uh yeah they all kneeled to him and
all the black inmates are just like oh
no yeah i uh you see it because again uh
coming coming from just being like a
newcomer to this peacemaker this
universe really i uh and not reading
like any of the comics uh i'm just like
what i was like white supremacists in
this show
i guess it's not too far off you know
you'd be surprised how many white
supremacist super villains they were
which is funny because you know now
we're in this like generation where all
these like nerds are like
can comics stop being so pc i'm like
there are so many they've been so many
times superman has beat up so many races
yeah yeah you know it's like what are
you talking about
they've been doing that they've been
they've been
no i think this episode was great it had
a lot of things uh to like just a lot i
guess we got some of the answers yeah
not really but like we got some you guys
i mean it's episode two yeah so it'd be
a little too early to get all the
answers we're slowly getting into it i'm
i'm obsessed with vigilante he's my he's
the best look
look
if if a friend's close enough to have a
threesome with you know that's a good
friend great that's a good friend yeah
but um i think you're talking about us
getting some answers let's get some more
answers oh yeah we've got to open this
interview yeah get this interview with
chakuti absolutely
[Music]
hello hello everyone and right now i am
so happy to say we're joined by the
incredible shikuri iwuji who plays mern
how are you doing
i'm doing well and i'm always happy when
people can pronounce my name quite well
the versions i've heard over the years
oh yeah thank you thank you for nailing
that you're nigerian yeah and i cheated
because my name is
sir we share half
half our names are the same right yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
well but thank you so much for sitting
in with us we're excited to chat about
the show we're excited about your
characters so i'm gonna just jump right
into it and just start asking questions
okay
so mern seems to have been tasked with
saving the world with a pain of misfits
at his disposal what is it like dealing
with that burden of leadership amongst
this dysfunctional team
um oh it's hilarious because i think
that's a classic example of where life
definitely meets art because as the
actor has jacobi the actor working with
john and danielle and stephen you know
jen i mean
they're just and they're just hilarious
they're just hilarious people and then
you have james who encourages hilarity
and madness you know from the god mikes
out there going try doing this keep
doing this so there was a side of me
that was trying to just keep it together
uh with the actors and then there's of
course mern
the character trying to keep it together
with a team he refers to as the apple
dumpling gang you know like that sort of
mania you see sort of creeping up in man
was actually a slight mania creeping up
in chicouti so it all works really
really really nicely and also my
background is just not about improv and
all that you know when you come from
theater you don't improvise shakespeare
you don't improvise checkup or you're
running into a cul-de-sac so these guys
are great at improving and just going
with this i'm very just like saying
please god don't let don't ask me to
improvise don't have to surprise so that
sort of reads us keep your [ __ ] together
so actually life or not sort of came
together nicely there you know
i mean just like you said you have such
a theater background but in this show
there seems to be like a lot of
vulnerable and emotional moments how do
you
do you ever prepare for a scene like
that
i prepare for those scenes the same way
as i prepare for every other scene and
it's really honestly it's i i learned my
lines i drill my lines
hundreds of times um there is no
i always get wary about answering these
sort of questions because there's
there's
nothing necessarily sexy about how i
prepare i can go look at salamanders in
the bronx zoo you know or
try to imitate the
agility of a tiger or give up my
apartment and live on the streets to
know what it's like to feel homeless i
don't i use imagination and that's what
my learning my lines is about so that
when i turn up on set
all that's important is that other
person because all my imagination work
and all prepper can never prepare you
for the energy of the other actor in
front of you and your availability for
them and also this whole thing about
getting yourself into an emotional state
before the scene is a weird it doesn't
make sense to me because usually in the
scene you enter it not emotional and
then you get emotional
so the journey is what's interesting
watching you become that if you've
already come in with that
that's kind of a weird cheat that never
reads true to me and it just i
it feels like i've come to play the end
game instead of come to enjoy the
journey so i i i just believe in
learning the lines getting yourself
relaxed coming in there and whatever
imagination you've had
those ideas you have have them but be
ready for all that to change when
there's this other x factor in front of
you which is the other performer
and and and and chemistry
okay i like that i do think you know i
think you're right and it really
changes the way i think about you know
approaching a scene
we're like getting some
five star acting
acting classes right now seriously oh
yeah 100
so in this episode we see peacemaker
trying to escape from the apartment
complex but his priorities get thrown
off by some sweet vinyl
if you had to flee a crime scene and
could only grab five records
what would they be
oh that's that's not right
five
yeah uh
score by the fuji's
tom waits meal variations
i would need some kind of that's like
listening music i would need sort of
music for mood so for me my mood set
setting is usually classical and opera
so i'm going to cheat here and i'm going
to make a compilation that's both opera
and classical so has to include as far
as the classical music i love piano
concerto so just the kovich's concerto
number two
mozart concerto 20 21 23 and then as far
as
opera goes as long as you give me lots
of verdi la traviata you know um
has to be in there i need
marriage of figaro from mozart i need uh
the elixir of love
um
yeah so as long as those are in there
and
finally
peter gabriel
his album so but i would need you to
sneak in a version of him singing biko
from his peter gabriel sings live
concert
that i'm good honorable mention for
barry white who always makes me happy
yeah so yeah so yeah you know you have
to have that so that's my collection
that's a solid collection right there so
in a similar vein that the scene where
peacemaker has to essentially hide from
the cops and convince strangers to let
them in let him in his in their house
if that were to happen to you let's say
you're fleeing from the cops and you
have to hide in a stranger's house how
would you convince them to let you in
this is this is really bad i'm sorry
this isn't me i love animals and i
especially love dogs but knowing how
much i love dogs i would grab their dog
preferably a small really cute shoe dog
hold it in front of me and say
if you don't hide me i'm gonna shout
i'm coming out with a gun
with your dog in front of you
so if you don't hide me i'm shouting
that and i'm stepping into that hallway
with your dog in front of me and i think
i think i think they would hide me
that's exactly
yeah i feel so bad i'm going to get so
many complaints
you're right
that was the only right answer actually
it wouldn't let you into their house
you're right
like appeal build to their wants and
knees yeah
yeah absolutely it's psychology 101 yeah
oh yeah
you know it seems like you know that's a
stressful situation and you know they we
all like to relieve that stress so
much like you know peacemaker and
vigilante did uh this episode if you had
the chance to take your stress out on
some appliances what weapon would you
choose and what appliance would be your
first target i hate technology and at
the risk of never
becoming a spokesman for mac
i would take a really good golf club and
i don't even play golf and i would
pretty much smash
oh my tech they drive me nuts every day
at some point every day even prepping
for this today
my email for some reason wasn't arriving
on my ipad and i was like i need that to
get the zoom link i mean everything was
going wrong so it would be that i would
take it out on
all my technology and it feel really
good and again an honorable mention if i
didn't do that
if it wasn't my technology
something that really bugs me when i go
to people's homes
are porcelain dolls
i have a problem with porcelain dolls
they're scary their eyes follow you
around the place and there's always lots
of them so
baseball bat to porcelain dolls they're
not appliances technically but i would
like to smash those up that's my yeah
we'll
we'll allow it in this occasion
the porcelain dolls count as appliances
and you can smash them in their creepy
eyes up
so we love seeing you play mern but like
what was your favorite part of being
mirn and just playing as him
always cool to play
someone with a dark past sort of
working on redemption that's always such
a great arc for an
actor
because there's just so much you like to
sort of live in the darkness but
redemption is something you look for you
know what i mean so i love that i love
the acting challenge of being british
nigerian and i've dipped my toe into
playing americans in past you know like
all the things on the ground railroad
and stuff like that you know which has
been fun but it was great to have this
whole arc of this deeply america even
the name clemson which is a very
southern name i mean just having this
deeply steeped american role over the
course of the whole series was such a
joy for me working with my dialect coach
cody callum and just like saying
i've got to become someone else you know
and coming up with i've got to find his
voice placement everything
energistically is so different that i i
enjoyed that sort of level of forensic
detail in preparation for him whether it
was working on you know
vowel substitutions and dialects or
um sort of working on what his
background is because there's not much
known about him and james you know
really you know created this character
he's not a character in the comic books
you know so
like i i had him in my head he came from
west point he was the best of the best
he goes into black ops what what
triggered the slide to make him known as
this dangerous character so i loved all
that i loved immersing myself in that
and i loved coming into work every day
because it's it's it's it's a real gift
when
the crew are interested you know the
crew are the real litmus test
you know when the crew and the grip and
all these guys that have seen it a
hundred times they're going on to when
they they're laughing and laughing hard
and the camera is shaking because the
camera operator is laughing really hard
you know you're doing something really
fun um so
i really enjoyed playing
really having a go at this very american
of um american characters for me you
know in that environment
yeah
yeah i think mirn is one of the
one of my favorites i think he's like a
really awesome character and you really
kind of see you see that there's so many
layers to him which i bet it was so much
fun to play and to experiment with it
really was especially with that apple
dumpling gang of people where my
instinct you know it's a bit is it's a
bit like when you you see uh
vince vaughn play the straight man in a
comedy yeah i really wanted to get in on
all the crazy fun with them but i had to
keep it together and that was a very fun
challenge of being that guy that just
keeps it together with this crew you
know yeah
oh okay so much fun well listen iffy
guess what time it is yeah yeah favorite
segment yeah yeah
eagley mail
[Music]
so to wrap out the interview we're gonna
take a question from the community what
unexpected challenges did you face on
set or in your performance that you
overcame well there was one really funny
one at the beginning which is a bit of a
segue but my first day on set i arrive
and there's like 100 people there i'm
already nervous worrying if the cow will
still be there to pick me up at the end
of the day thinking they've made a
mistake they actually thought i was
chewatel in jail for not
they've hired the wrong actor and i had
to drill i had to drill use an electric
drill and drill
some screws into a tree
in the scene now the problem is i'm the
sort of guy that when i change a light
bulb i feel like i've accomplished
something major i do not do diy i mean i
at one point i had the drills set to
reverse instead of forward but the nail
kept falling i it was it was a nightmare
i was sure i was going to get fired so
that was the first day challenge but
overall the challenge for me was like
and every actor i feel at least for me i
still have to get over um an imposter
syndrome
oh yeah that
do they really want me am i really doing
this am i really doing a james gone
project is that really james gone direct
to me am i acting with these guys am i
playing this clemson man this ex i mean
it's a dream to like be a cool guy that
knows how to handle a gun and be like
yeah i mean it's all that stuff so for
me the biggest challenge was dropping
into that literally dropping in vocally
physically
an economy of movement
i mean those guys think in a different
way you see them
you you see guys like that they're very
economical you know with how they move
and stuff and learning that
and trusting that and then letting it
all go so that like we said at the
beginning of this segment so that the
most important thing which is all great
drama is is
two people talking to each other being
able to let that go trust it's there and
know know that you're gonna do that so
it was
massive leaps of faith for me every day
but it was such a worthy challenge
because i i really enjoyed the texture
of this character because so much was
going on with him that he never says as
you know fiona mentioned like
there's so much underneath the surface
with him that you've just got to trust
that because you're living it it's
showing because you can't
just show it does that make sense so
that was a that was a great learning
curve even at this stage in my career
for me as an actor to play a role like
that you know
it seemed like it just seemed like you
had so much fun with the character and
also just with all your other co-workers
they look it looks like such a fun time
shooting so we had it we genuinely did
have a great we've had such a magical
time it's so much fun
that's so great to hear everyone's been
really great i know i'm so excited to
see the journey of mern this season and
the rest of the peacemaker but thank you
so much for coming to chat with us it
was so fun thank you thank you so much
for having me this was really easy thank
god not like setting up was but
the interview part was very easy thank
you
all right well we'll see you uh and i
guess we'll get back to the rest of the
show fiona
i just pretended to look at my fake
watch on my wrist so you know what time
it is what time is it it's time for the
peace prize
[Music]
ooh peace prize
yeah so the peace prize is a prize we
give out every episode from a moment in
the episode that really stuck with us in
a good way last last episode we had the
eagley hug but we got something a little
different this week yeah this week
listen we got some vulnerability with
peacemaker okay he's sad he's deciding
if violence truly is the answer
which
it is
yes which is a yes
but we also have this his stalker friend
vigilante that comes up tries to console
him in some way so i think the prize
we're gonna give is the death to peace
prize
which is when vigilante and peacemaker
go out there and just shoot some
appliances
[Music]
look cinema has taught us long long ago
that the best way to let out a little
anger is to take it out on some old
appliances so you know we got to we got
to see that again and uh using a high
powered weaponry too and i thought that
was so cool just having high power
weapons and like a forest just like
shooting like microwaves and so it's
great i love that oh yeah i also think
like
again like i know we're joking about it
but you really do see that relationship
that they have which i'm all about
relationships that people have with
others and i really do feel like they
even though vigilante is that kind of
weird stalkerish fanboy
kind of guy
i think peacemaker really does care for
him and i think they're like a really
good pair so i and i i think they also
just jump like the riffing off of one
another is just amazing so i i don't
know i think this deserved the peace
prize for this week um
i love them i also really love vigilante
yeah number one fan girl here i think uh
i think we're we're all becoming fans of
vigilante at this point
uh but unfortunately uh
that's all we have for this episode
that's all we have so you know thank you
for watching and listening to podly the
official peacemaker companion podcast
from hbo max and dc now make sure you go
ahead and subscribe to tune in to the
next episode where we break down episode
number three you know you get it now you
know after episode two comes three and
then after three is going to come four
yeah
yeah counting numbers and also if you
want some amazing merch just head on
over to
shop.dccomics.com and you can just get
some sweet peacemaker merchandise and
show off your fan spirit for the show oh
yeah yeah and don't forget to follow us
on twitter instagram and facebook and
let us know what were some of your
favorite moments in the show and if you
want to get tapped into the source
material remember you can get that dc
universe infinite membership and you'll
have access to all the comics all the
things this show touch into because look
james gunn is doing some deep cuts and
with dc universe infinite you'll be able
to find those cuts and i will be
registering for a membership that will
be me okay and of course make sure you
stream peacemaker and podley on hbo max
so you can stay up to date with all this
dopeness
we love it we love it i can't wait for
episode three and i can't wait to see
you guys next time yeah yeah so see you
around and uh keep the peace keep the
peace i love it we're doing it we're
keeping it
you